we have a voicemail number you can call
any time we had
hundreds and hundreds of voicemails
waiting for us
when we got back from our vacation
let's listen to one who is pointing out
you know david these
live streams are getting so crazy
that it's almost impossible to even use
the chat function
i there's something funny and quaint
about this one take a listen
hey david i just wanted to say i
apologize if buggy
anyway i'll just say it um can you make
some sort of statement for your um
live shows about the live chat because
people just speed through and there's a
hundred statements and you can't even
read it it's like right
there's no interaction at all it's just
a lot of
like word salads well well
word salads should be the motto for
youtube live stream chat yeah i mean i
agree
at 100 miles an hour so there's no
conversation
like no i wish youtube had like a uh
you know you could only make a statement
maybe every five seconds
it's called slow mode we use it uh we
have it turned on
it's actually set to 10 seconds but it's
just it they get crazy i admit it
because there's something like that
but it's just insane like it there's
you might as well not even have it
turned off
[Laughter]
there's something so quaint and
delightful about you know
during these when this when the stream
has a lot of people watching it
the live chat is almost completely
worthless and unusable and
and it's unclear whether it should even
be on i completely agree with you yeah
that's why i don't even look at it
uh and maybe you shouldn't either but i
i just love that it's like welcome to
the internet my friend yeah that's how
it works no but we do use slow mode
we could slow it down even more we could
set it to 30 seconds but
sometimes people get frustrated we we
want we want the chat to be available to
people who want it
much like youtube comments but it's also
easy to ignore
it and them the live chat and comments
respectively
if you just want to focus on the content
so my view is something for everyone
have everything turned on but only use
what you like
today's bonus show i will tell you
wacky anti-vaxx stories
from my vacation in florida
some of the things happened in florida
some of the things happened in florida
and you'll know which or which as i
explain it to you on today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com we'll hear
about what pat was up to it'll be great
and i'll speak to you then